[Musique]
au mileu françois croissance de bons
scores des talons hauts
[Musique]
l'asie
alida a fait des efforts travers il faut
que ce coup de là il l'oeil non plus au
plus haut plus haut non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais j'avais des copains on se retrouve
à 20h sur ses news
pour l'heure des pros de on va
évidemment débriefer l'après-midi des
bleus à l'elysée et on va parler de la
légion d'honneur a tout de suite non
[Musique]
mais beaucoup de monde j'espère que vous
allez bien alors j'ai reçu beaucoup
beaucoup de messages à propos du concert
de maxime la note qui se déroule ce soir
donc on a créé beaucoup de temps et à
propos des places que vous m'avez
demandé il n'en reste plus que 10 on
sait déjà qu'on on va vous donner les
dix places contre les dix personnes
sélectionnées pour aller ce soir au
concert gratuitement c'est maya
[Applaudissements]
c'est le retour de beyoncé tiers pour le
coup pas mal pas mal et thibault oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et le son
amélie mauresmo allez donc si tu sers
comme ça on est pas dans la merde des
passe droits
[Applaudissements]
ça y est je les trouvais bon olivier
linot comme en bonne compagnie là
c'était hésiter gens là quand j'ai connu
nos bois tout va bien chez non et c'est
cette offre était chaud et beaucoup de
monde j'ai envie d'y retourner et bon
encontre et ami intime de sa soif
essayez le monde espoirs c'est vrai que
je n'avais les soirs on avait de
l'espoir le coeur brisé et le coeur vous
aident ou le bleu blanc rouge que tu es
arrivé aujourd'hui ben oui les points et
les mets toi c'est moi ou les toiles
away du champion du monde bravo entre de
l'ensemble je suis à la recherche
[Musique]
ont été posées là tranquillement
vautours tranquillement
[Musique]
un job durant cinq mois du show de
concevoir que quand je danse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]